العديد من الارقام والاحصائيات سجلت خلال
مباريات يوم امس بعد تاهل البرازيل
وكرواتيا على حسابي كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان البرازيل اكملت مسيرتها الناجحه
امام المنتخبات الاسيويه في كاس العالم
محققه انتصارها الرابعه على منتخبات
القاره البرازيل ايضا تسجل لثاني مره في
تاريخها بمباراه اقصائيه اكثر مما سجلت
بدور المجموعات كاملا منذ مونديال عام
1978 اما بالنسبه لكرواتيا فقد وصلت المره
الثالثه بتاريخ المشاركاتها بكاس العالم
للدور ربع النهائي بعد مونديال 1998 و 28
بركلات الجزاء في كاس العالم بعد فوزها
على الدنمارك وروسيا في 2018 واليابان في
اليابان تخفق مره جديده في الفوز بمباراه
الاقصائيه في كاس العالم بعد خسارتها
للمره الرابعه بتاريخ مشاركاتها في نفس
المرحله بعد ركلات الترجيح بين كرو
واليابان وصلت عدد الركلات الترجيحيه
المسجله الى 200 مقابل 87 ضائعه بتاريخ
المونديال